hi wir sind heute wieder für euch bei
ZDF heute live und wenn ihr euch jetzt
fragt wer ist die denn ich bin Victoria
Reichelt ich bin die Neue und ich freue
mich sehr hier heute und zukünftig mit
euch zu diskutieren wir sprechen heute
über China genauer gesagt über die
massiven Proteste die es dort in Peking
in Shanghai und in anderen Städten gab
seit dem Wochenende gehen dort Menschen
auf die Straße um gegen die strikte nur
mit Politik von Staatspräsident
protestieren auslöser war ein
Wohnungsbrand in der Millionenstadt im
Nordwesten des Landes da sind zehn
Menschen gestorben und das vermutlich
weil ihr Gebäude wegen Corona
abgeriegelt war und heute gab es auch
Proteste in Hongkong die Menschen dort
halten weiße Zettel hoch und legen
Blumen wieder wie damals vor drei Jahren
als sie in der chinesischen
sonderverwaltung Zone gegen den
Machteinfluss der Volksrepublik
demonstriert haben
ja und das ist tatsächlich die größte
Protestwelle seit Jahrzehnten die wir da
gerade durch verschiedene Fotos und
Videos aus China mitbekommen und
deswegen fragen wir uns heute hier kann
diese corona-wut der chinesischen Bürger
und Bürgerinnen Machthaber Chi und der
kommunistischen Regierung eigentlich
gefährlich werden und das bespreche ich
mit zwei ExpertInnen auf dem Gebiet zum
einen mit unserer Korrespondentin in
Peking Miriam Steimer und mit der
Professorin Christine Kupfer vom
china-institut der Uni Trier wenn ihr
Fragen an die beiden habt oder
Kommentare zu unserer Sendung zum Thema
dann könnt ihr wie immer mit diskutieren
und uns die einfach schicken schreibt
uns die gerne in den Chat oder per Mail
an ZDF heute - live at zdf.de jetzt
begrüßt ja aber erstmal Miriam Steimer
live aus Peking schön dass du bei uns
bist
ja hallo Miriam du warst am Sonntagabend
direkt in den Straßen Pekings bei den
Demonstrierenden und mich hat das
ehrlich gesagt überrascht dass diese
massiven Proteste überhaupt so
stattfinden konnten hat dich das
überrascht und wie war so dein Eindruck
ja mich hat das ja auch überrascht da
irgendwann mittendrin zu stehen wir
waren eigentlich hier im Studio am am
arbeiten und haben gerade Material
gesichtet aus Shanghai und haben
irgendwann mitbekommen dass diese Demo
dann auch hier in Peking anfingen und
haben uns das natürlich angeguckt es war
vor allem überraschend wie viele Leute
tatsächlich auf der Straße waren muss
man vielleicht noch mal in Erinnerung
rufen also in China auf eine
Demonstration zu gehen ist ja leider was
ganz anderes als in Deutschland auf
Demonstration zu gehen also du hast
schon gesagt sind so massive Proteste so
viele Menschen auf der Straße wie wir
das seit Jahrzehnten nicht gesehen haben
und jeder einzelne Mensch der da auf die
Straße geht muss mit Konsequenzen
rechnen also es gab ja schon
Verhaftungen aber auch wenn es nicht
direkte Verhaftungen sind also Leute die
da dabei waren berichten dass sie danach
Anrufe von der Polizei bekommen haben
oder Besuche von der Staatssicherheit
das sie oder auch Familie oder Freunde
unter Druck gesetzt wurden also ist
einfach ein total großes Risiko sich
hier an so einer Demonstration zu
beteiligen umso überraschender wie viele
Menschen das in China gerade machen
ja über diese überraschenden Proteste
sprechen wir gleich noch im Detail und
auch über ihre Beweggründe und erst
einmal schauen wir uns jetzt aber noch
ein Bericht von dir zu aktuellen Lage an
in Shanghai endete die Demonstration
gestern Abend für viele so wie viele
genau festgenommen wurden gibt die
Polizei nicht bekannt sicher ist unter
ihnen war auch dieser Reporter der
britischen BBC der von den Protesten
berichtete erst nach Stunden kam er
wieder frei das ist Chinas Verständnis
von Pressefreiheit
in vielen Städten wie hier in muhan
waren Menschen auf die Straße gegangen
um gegen die strikten corona-maßnahmen
zu demonstrieren
in Peking brachten sie Blumen und Kerzen
für die Toten die den nicht
wissenschaftlichen corona-maßnahmen und
der uneingeschränkten macht zum Opfer
gefallen sind
denn Auslöser der Proteste war ein
Wohnungsbrand im Nordwesten Chinas
mindestens zehn Menschen kamen dabei ums
Leben ihr Tod löste einen Sturm der
Entrüstung aus viele glauben dass die
Menschen wegen corona-absperrungen nicht
gerettet werden konnten
ohne das zu erwähnen kündigte die
Stadtverwaltung in Peking heute an
künftig keine Zäune mehr aufzustellen um
die Eingänge von Wohnanlagen im Lockdown
zu blockieren die staatliche Zensur ist
im Dauereinsatz dass der Protest auch
von der Straße verschwindet dafür soll
die Polizei sorgen
ja wir haben es hier gesehen die
Proteste sollen von der Straße
verschwinden Miriam wie brenzlig ist die
Situation denn aktuell gestern warst du
ja noch mittendrin auf der Straße
heute ist es erstaunlich ruhig wir haben
schon heute morgen gesehen wir waren
wieder an dem Ort wo gestern die
Demonstration war und das war ein
massives Polizeiaufgebot also noch mehr
Polizistinnen und Polizisten als das
gestern Abend schon der Fall war das ist
glaube ich auch der Grund warum es heute
nicht zu größeren Protesten kam also es
gab während des Tages viele Gerüchte
Verabredungen wir haben immer wieder
gehört dann und dann dort und dort soll
was stattfinden aber eigentlich so waren
alle neuralgischen Punkte mit so einer
Polizeipräsenz besetzt ja das ist glaube
ich gar nicht möglich war also alles was
wir heute sehen sind sind Videos von
einzeln
Demonstranten oder Demonstranten die mit
der Polizei aneinander geraten oder von
kleinen Gruppen aber es hat definitiv
nicht dieses Ausmaßen dass wir am
Wochenende erlebt haben in Shanghai zum
Beispiel in der Straße in der
protestiert wurde stehen jetzt auch
diese großen blauen Absperrungen also
ist so ein Protest wie am Wochenende
stattfand auch gar nicht mehr möglich
du hast es eben schon angesprochen dass
besondere an diesem Protesten war ja
wirklich die Masse an Menschen Miriam
was waren das denn für Leute die da auf
der Straße protestiert haben kannst du
das irgendwie charakterisieren
also in der Demo in der wir hier in
Peking waren waren das vor allem junge
Menschen wir haben natürlich auch einige
Fragen wie wie organisiert ihr euch denn
das ist natürlich auch in der Diktatur
in dieser totalen Überwachung viel
schwieriger so ein Protest überhaupt zu
organisieren und und einer erzählte mir
ähm ja wir haben das über Instagram
gemacht das hat mich doch überrascht
weil man muss dazu müssen Instagram darf
man in China eigentlich gar nicht
benutzen also funktioniert hier
eigentlich nicht das heißt wenn man das
benutzen möchte muss man sogenannten VPN
benutzen also eine App die sozusagen
eine vorspiegelt dass man in einem
anderen Land sitzt um freies Internet zu
haben um so eine App nutzen zu können
also bei den bei den Menschen die ich
jetzt gesehen habe und gesprochen habe
bei der Demo hier in Peking das waren
definitiv eine junge Generation eine
technisch sehr viele Generation und auch
eine Generation die in sehr kreativen
Prozess Prozess sucht oder Protest hat
was aber wirklich das Besondere an
diesen Protesten ist ist
einfach die ganze Bevölkerung betroffen
ist also normalerweise ist es ja so es
gibt ein Grund der irgendwie eine
bestimmte Gruppe betrifft also nehmen
wir die Beispiele der Ausschreitungen in
dem fox-konverb Werk von diesem Apple
Zulieferer da geht es natürlich genau um
diese Arbeiter die dort arbeiten aber
die strengen corona-maßnahmen hier in
China die treffen jeden also egal ob
jung ob alt ob Armen oder reich wenn man
irgendwie in seiner Wohnung eingesperrt
wird und nicht mehr arbeiten kann oder
wenn man wenn man positiv auf Corona
getestet wird in so eine
Massenunterkunft in so ein
quarantänezentrum Muss oder wenn man
keinen aktuellen PCR-Test hat und
deshalb nicht mehr in Supermarkt kommt
das trifft einfach die ganze Bevölkerung
gleichermaßen und ich glaube das ist
auch das Besondere an diesem Protest
gerade
wir haben sie in deinem Beitrag auch
gesehen auslöser für diese Proteste
jetzt war unter anderem auch dieser
Brand in dem Wohnhaus aus dem
wahrscheinlich Leute nicht fliehen
konnten wegen dieser corona-maßnahmen
meinst du das hat auch noch mal eine
Dringlichkeit hervorgerufen weil dieser
Lockdown ja gerade ganz ganz viele
Menschen betrifft die im Ernstfall auch
nicht aus diesen Häusern könnten
ja ich glaube das ist tatsächlich so der
Tropfen gewesen der das fast zum
Überlaufen gebracht hat wie man so schön
sagt also dieser Wohnhausbrand und und
die Todesopfer dort und die Vermutung
dass die wirklich nicht rauskam weil
Türen verriegelt waren weil die
Feuerwehr nicht durch Absperrungen durch
kamen um rechtzeitig bei diesem Brand zu
sein das hat wirklich ganz viele
erzählen ich glaube es hat zwei Gründe
das eine ist im das einfach gerade
Millionen Menschen in diesem Land selbst
im Lockdown sitzen die coronazahlen sind
ja gerade in China auf einem Rekord hoch
im Vergleich zu anderen Ländern immer
noch niedrig aber für China ist es eine
Rekordzahl und sitzen wirklich viele
Menschen in ihrem Wohnungen und fragen
sich natürlich wie wäre das denn
eigentlich bei mir würde ich eigentlich
hier rauskommen wenn es brennen würde
oder wenn es ein Erdbeben geben würde
und das andere ist ähm das viele
erzählen sind weil es gab eine
offizielle Pressekonferenz nach nach
diesem nach diesem Brand und da wurde
nicht gesagt dass dieses Haus unter
Lockdown schon das ist immer noch nicht
offiziell bestätigt aber viele haben
diese Vermutung dort wurde aber gesagt
dass ein Grund warum historisches Opfer
gab war dass sozusagen die Menschen
selbst nicht die richtigen Fähigkeiten
gehabt hätten um sich daraus zu befreien
und das hat wirklich ganz viele extrem
erzürnt die die halt sagen jetzt es
liegt an sie vermuten das liegt an
diesem corona-maßnahmen und dann wird
auch noch gesagt die Menschen werden
daran selbst schuld gewesen also das ist
wirklich in protest den wir auch gestern
hier bei der Demo gespürt haben also
ganz viele hatten natürlich diese weißen
Blätter dabei über die wir bestimmt auch
noch sprechen aber auch Blumen und
Kerzen also diese das Gedenken an die
Menschen die dort in diesem
hochhausbrand umgekommen sind war
sozusagen der eigentliche Grund oder
zumindest die Verabredung warum die
Menschen sich auf der Straße getroffen
haben
du hast es gerade schon angesprochen die
Zahlen in China sind hoch lass uns da
mal einen Blick drauf werfen
es gab zum einen im Frühjahr so ein peak
in China mit den coronazahlen es gibt
aber gerade quasi noch stärker
ansteigende zahlen das sehen wir jetzt
hier in der Grafik und hier den pink ist
ja auch bekannt für seine strikte
nullcover Politik Miriam vielleicht
kannst Du noch mal ganz kurz das Ausmaß
dieser Maßnahmen beschreiben also was
heißt das jeden Tag für die Menschen in
China und mich würde interessieren wie
würde denn so ein lockern dieser
Maßnahmen überhaupt aussehen ist China
als Land darauf vorbereitet weil die
fahren diese 0 Politiker jetzt schon
echt lange
also null Comic Politik das bedeutet
zuerst mal dass jeder einzelne Ausbruch
also jeder einzelne Fall mit extremen
Maßnahmen bekämpft werden soll also das
bedeutet dann dass zum Beispiel extreme
kontaktnachverfolgung gibt also über die
technischen Möglichkeiten die es gibt
ich muss ja überall wo ich hier hingehe
wenn ich ein Restaurant gehe oder ein
Supermarkt was in PGE gerade alles
geschlossen ist mich einscannen mit mit
einer App das heißt ich lasse ich
überlasse überall in in digitalen
Fingerabdruck es gibt aber auch noch
sozusagen Big Data also ich werde
sowieso überall getrackt wo ich bin weil
ich ohne mein Handy in China überhaupt
nichts machen kann also diese
kontaktverfolgung was in Deutschland ja
oft sind zu Beginn der war nämlich auch
ein Problem war das funktioniert ja
einwandfrei und es wird wirklich bei
jedem einzelnen Ausbruch extrem viele
Menschen werden mit isoliert also aus
wirklich aus dem Bestreben jeden
einzelnen Ausbruch zu bekämpfen so
extreme Maßnahmen bedeutet dann
lockdowns und Lockdown bedeutet dann im
Zweifel auch dass ich einfach meine
Wohnung nicht mehr verlassen darf oder
dass wenn ich positiv getestet bin auch
nicht in meiner Wohnung bleiben darf
sondern in einen quarantäne-hotel in ein
Krankenhaus oder in eine
Massenunterkunft muss ob ich das möchte
oder nicht das ist einfach die Regel
also ich bin dann ein muss dann einfach
mitgehen
wir hier in Peking zum Beispiel müssen
uns jeden Tag zur Zeit testen also ich
gehe jeden Tag zur Teststation und mache
meinen PCR-Test das wird in meiner in
meiner App hinterlegt wenn ich selbst
wenn ich in meinen Wohnkomplex möchte
muss ich mich einscannen und vorweisen
dass ich diesen nicht älter als 24
Stunden PCR-Test habe
du hast schon gesagt ich hätte den Ping
hat das zu zu seiner zu seiner Politik
gemacht also er hat diese Null corbit
Politik ganz klar mit seinem Namen mit
seinem Kopf verbunden das ist sein sein
Baby und er hat auch immer betont dass
das sozusagen der der dieses systemische
Überlegenheit ist also die
Staatspropaganda erzählt den Menschen
hier jetzt seit fast drei Jahren dass
China das alles macht um Menschenleben
zu schützen also der ja die Propaganda
ist sozusagen der besten der kümmert
sich nicht um seine Leute da sterben die
Menschen an Corona aber wir kümmern uns
um unseren Erfolg und sorgen dafür dass
er niemand stirbt zu deiner Frage wie
das jetzt mit Lockerungen aussehen
könnte das ist gar nicht so einfach weil
es gibt einen großen Unterschied wenn
man jetzt z.B die deutsche Bevölkerung
mit der chinesischen vergleicht nicht
nur zahlenmäßig sondern z.B auch von der
Immunisierung also in China haben
einfach sehr sehr wenige Menschen
überhaupt nur Corona gehabt durch diese
Politik es gibt also nicht zwischen den
anderen Ländern gibt es gibt außerdem
hat man beim Impfen angefangen die zu
impfen und nicht die alten zu impfen das
führt dazu dass es eine impflücke oder
eine zu niedrige Impfquote gibt gerade
in dieser vulnerablen Gruppe der älteren
also die über 80-Jährigen zum Beispiel
da sind nur 66 Prozent geimpft wenn wir
über Boostern sprechen dann sind es nur
noch 40 Prozent dazu kommen die
Impfstoffe hier werden nur chinesische
Impfstoffe verimpft das sind
vektorimpfstoffe im RNA Impfstoffe gibt
es noch keinen chinesischen und die aus
dem Westen also sowas wie biontech oder
moderner dafür nicht verimpft werden
jetzt liegen Studien aber nahe dass
diese chinesischen Impfstoffe gegen
gerade gegen die Omegon Variante des
Coronavirus nicht so wirksam sind wie
dass die mRNA Impfstoffe sind auch das
Gesundheitssystem spielt hier eine Rolle
also wenn wenn man jetzt einfach hier
die die Regeln öffnen also lockern würde
öffnen würde dann wäre auch das
Gesundheitssystem das krankenhaussystem
sehr schnell an einem Limit das alles
führt also dazu dass so schnelle
Lockerungen hier nicht die Aussicht sind
die alle haben also ist ja im Sommer
immer ja nach dem Parteitag wird es
besser jetzt heißt es ja nach dem
Volkskongress im Frühjahr wird es besser
ich bin gespannt was die nächste
Deadline ist aber so ein richtig guten
Ausweg sehe ich gerade noch nicht
ja danke für deine Ausführung noch mal
ich glaube das zeigt noch mal ganz gut
dass die chinesischen Maßnahmen echt
ganz schön hart sind im Vergleich zu dem
was wir vielleicht in Deutschland an
corona-maßnahmen erlebt haben ich habe
hier eine Frage aus der Community für
dich vom YouTube User RB Frau Steimer
gehen Sie davon aus dass die
Demonstranten nur eine kleine Minderheit
repräsentieren oder genießen Sie den
Rückhalt weiterteile der Bevölkerung die
sich vielleicht nicht trauen zu
demonstrieren
ja das ist eine gute Frage also es gibt
bestimmt auch Leute die sich nicht
trauen aber bei diesem Protesten ist
wirklich auch noch mal wichtig zu sagen
das ist ein kleiner Teil der Bevölkerung
also ganz viele Menschen in diesem Land
kriegen von diesen Protesten überhaupt
gar nichts mit in den chinesischen im
chinesischen Netz werden alle Fotos alle
Videos von diesen Protesten zensiert das
heißt es gibt ganz viele Menschen im
Land die überhaupt gar nicht wissen dass
es diese Proteste gibt und das ist schon
auch noch mal wichtig zu sagen es gibt
auch wirklich viele Menschen in diesem
Land die die corona-politik die diese
strikte corona-politik unterstützen das
hat natürlich auch mit der Verfügbarkeit
von Informationen hier zu tun also
Menschen die keinen VPN ich habe ihm
schon erklärt was ist nutzen oder die
will kein Zugang zu frei im Internet
oder freien Informationen haben die
haben natürlich einfach die
Informationen die die staatsoperander
Ihnen hier liefert und es gibt wirklich
auch ganz viele Menschen in diesem Land
die einfach Angst haben sich mit Corona
Insulin zu infizieren weil sie Angst
haben dass das tödlich sein könnte oder
dass das für ihre Familie tödlich sein
kann
ich glaube das beantwortet auch ganz
gute die Frage von YouTube User Bernhard
wie groß der Anteil der Bevölkerung ist
der überhaupt grundsätzlich mit dem
System unzufrieden ist du hast gesagt es
bekommen ja nicht mal alle Menschen von
diesen Protesten mit also auch in
Informationsfluss ist in China
tatsächlich ein Problem so abschließend
würde ich gerne noch mal deine
Einschätzung haben Miriam was glaubst du
was da so auf uns zukommt was wird sich
in China verändern und das fragt auch
Youtube gesagt Karlsruhe
1989 diese Prozesse sind zu klein um
China zu ändern aber vielleicht wird
hier motiviert seine Pläne zu ändern
manchmal fängt Änderung mit kleinen
Schritten an ist das was du teilst
ja das ist irgendwie die und dann
Millionen Dollar Frage wüsste ich
natürlich auch sehr gerne ich glaube
entscheidend sind wirklich was in den
nächsten Wochen passiert also wie wie
wird die chinesische Führung auf
Proteste reagieren wird es überhaupt
weitere Proteste geben gibt es eine
Möglichkeit die zu organisieren wer wird
das sein wer wird dahinter stehen also
ich habe ja schon erklärt dass auch alle
die die jetzt schon auf der Straße waren
mit entweder schon Konsequenzen gespürt
haben oder mit Konsequenzen rechnen
müssen das ist glaube ich eine ganz
entscheidende Frage das Polizeiaufgebot
dass wir heute auf der Straße sehen das
sieht eher so aussetzen könnte da nicht
so viel Nachkommen aber das ist wirklich
das ist wirklich die die entscheidende
Frage was passiert in den nächsten
Wochen und natürlich auch die Frage
inwiefern reagiert die chinesische
Führung auf diese Forderung also ich
weiß auch klingt jetzt in der Frage auch
noch mal an in wie viel Systemkritik ist
denn da wirklich dran also mein Eindruck
ist den allermeisten Menschen die wir
jetzt auf den Demonstrationen gesehen
haben geht es wirklich um Corona es geht
um die Corona Politik sie haben nach
drei Jahren wirklich die Nase voll sie
sehen das in anderen Ländern das Leben
inzwischen weitergeht das andere Länder
mit dem Coronavirus Leben und sehen dass
das in China nicht der Fall ist gerade
die Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft zurzeit
ist noch mal noch mal so ein Punkt der
zeigt wie es einfach woanders schon
wieder aussieht und das sind glaube ich
auch diese Forderungen nach Freiheit
diese Forderungen diese corona-politik
zu ändern das ist glaube ich wirklich
das Hauptanliegen dem der Mehrheit der
Menschen die hier auf die Straßen gehen
danke dir Miriam für deine Eindrücke aus
Peking wie sich die Situation in den
nächsten Tagen vielleicht auch Wochen
entwickeln wird das werden wir ja dann
von Dir erfahren vielen Dank
danke dir
ja wir haben es jetzt gehört diese
protestbilder sind vor allem in ihrer
Intensität überraschend der Unmut in der
chinesischen Bevölkerung der wächst aber
tatsächlich schon seit längerem immer
wieder kommt es dazu Protesten und zu
Ausschreitungen wie hier in guangoo da
haben aufgebrachte Textilarbeiter in
Absperrungen umgerissen weil sie wegen
Corona nicht in ihre Unterkünfte durften
[Applaus]
und als hier in changu ein ganzes
Industriegebiet abgeriegelt werden soll
haben tausende Menschen versucht zu
fliehen sie wollten nicht eingesperrt
sein auf dem Firmengelände und das
bringt uns noch mal zu der Frage können
diese Proteste in verschiedenen Teilen
Chinas jetzt aber auch wirklich für
gefährlich für verschiedene ping und
seine kommunistische Regierung werden
darüber sprechen wir jetzt mit
Professorin Christine Kupfer vom
china-institut der Uni Trier herzlich
willkommen hallo schönen guten Abend und
auch noch mal an euch im Stream der
Hinweis wenn ihr Fragen an Christine
Kupfer habt schreibt uns die gerne in
den Chat oder per Mail an ZDF heute -
live at zdf.de Frau Kupfer wie bewerten
sind sie die Reaktion der chinesischen
Sicherheitskräfte heute zum Beispiel in
Hongkong
bislang haben die chinesischen
Sicherheitskräfte ja alles in allem
relativ moderat reagiert sie haben
natürlich sind gegen einzelne Menschen
ohne Frage sehr brachial vorgegangen die
Bilder haben wir ja auch gesehen auch
gegen die ausländischen Journalisten
teilweise sie haben aber so habe ich es
beispielsweise aus Peking mitbekommen
doch zunächst versucht dann ja auch in
den frühen Morgenstunden beschwichtigend
auf die Leute einzuwirken bitte geht's
nach Hause natürlich jetzt die massive
Präsenz vor Ort ganz klar mit
Abriegelung aber auch eben mit
entsprechender Mann oder teilweise auch
Frau Präsenz also man setzt auf
Abschreckung es sind auch Bilder im
Internet zu sehen gewesen wo also
schwere gepanzerte Fahrzeuge
offensichtlich gerade in die Protest
Hochburgen nach Peking Shanghai und auch
wo Handeln
transportiert worden sind also alles in
allem setzt man doch jetzt sehr stark
auf Abschreckung und werde sicherlich
auch die Daten aus die man jetzt
gesammelt hat das ist ja sehr wichtig
dann aus Sicht der Behörden jetzt auch
entsprechende gerade sehr auffällige
Personen zu identifizieren und hat sich
bis jetzt Gott sei Dank nicht
entschieden mit aller Härte gegen die
Demonstranten vorzugehen
sie haben es gerade schon angesprochen
die
Reaktionen der chinesischen
Sicherheitskräfte waren ja erstmal
zumindest in der ersten protestnacht
relativ moderat und wir waren alle
verwundert darüber wie offen dort
protestiert werden konnte was glauben
Sie denn woran lag das waren die
chinesischen Sicherheitskräfte und die
Regierung überrascht von dieser
Protestwelle haben sie das nicht kommen
sehen
ich denke durchaus dass dort einen
Moment der Überraschung auf jeden Fall
vorhanden war gerade dann auch die
Gleichzeitigkeit die sicher dann im
Laufe der Nacht und dann vor allen
Dingen natürlich auch am zweiten Tag in
der zweiten Nacht deutlich gezeigt hat
ich glaube damit hat man nicht gerechnet
und man hat natürlich dann auch vor Ort
gewartet auf entsprechende Anweisung auf
Hinweise von den lokalen Behörden die
sich dann vermutlich wieder versucht
haben
zurückzuversichern auf nächste Ebene was
machen wir denn jetzt wie viel Härte
müssen wir einsetzen wie viel Daten
müssen wir sammeln wie viel Leute sollen
wir verhaften also das hat dann
natürlich etwas gedauert bis sich die
Behörden entsprechend organisiert haben
bzw auch die entsprechenden Anweisungen
erhalten haben
ich würde gerne mit Ihnen noch mal über
die Beweggründe für diese Proteste
sprechen wir haben ja eben in dem
Beitrag schon gesehen es gab zum einen
diesen tragischen Brand in dem Wohnhaus
wo Menschen quasi nicht fliehen konnten
es ist ja aber auch so dass wenn wir mal
auf das Wirtschaftswachstum in China
gucken da gerade eine ganz interessante
Entwicklung erleben das Wachstumsziel
für 2020 2022 in China lag bei 5,5% und
jetzt ist aber die Wachstumsprognose
tatsächlich nur bei 2,8 %. das ist
insofern interessant weil das in den
letzten Jahren auch häufiger mal in
zweistelligen Bereich lag in China und
dazu passt eine Frage eines Youtube
Users hier der fragt wie sehr wird hier
die Wirtschaft und damit den Wohlstand
der Bevölkerung noch gefährden weil es
ist ja so dass dieser
Wirtschaftseinbruch schon auch mit den
Corona lockdowns zusammenhängt
das ist genauso sehr wichtige Frage das
ist natürlich genau der Zielkonflikt der
von Anfang an vorhanden war und hier den
Ping bzw seine Unterstützer haben sich
offensichtlich lange Zeit für Stabilität
und Kontrolle um jeden Preis entschieden
also eben auch auf Kosten der Wirtschaft
es sind ja durch die stricken locknamen
lockdown-maßnahmen dann eben auch es
dazu gekommen dass bestimmte Fabriken
nicht produzieren konnten dass es
verzögerungen gab auch in der
Auslieferung in der Logistik was
natürlich auch dann noch mal diesen
Einbruch verschärft hat und das ist
jetzt in der Tat die große Frage ob man
jetzt doch was man angekündigt hatte
aber jetzt an der Umsetzung sich dann
natürlich messen lassen muss ob man
jetzt doch diese stricken
lockdown-maßnahmen jetzt allmählich
herunterfährt mit Blick auf die
Wirtschaftsentwicklung und jetzt
möglicherweise eben auch mit Blick auf
die zentralen Forderungen vieler
protestierender
wir haben uns ja eben schon angehört wer
denn da auf den Straßen ist und
protestiert und das sind ja vor allem
junge Menschen und man hört ja dort ganz
unterschiedliche Dinge eigentlich sind
das Proteste die aufgrund der strikten
Null covet-politik initiiert wurden
tatsächlich hört man aber auch
vereinzelt in Shanghai dann so rufe wie
nieder mit skijan Pink was ist denn ihre
Einschätzung wie steht es denn um diese
Erfolgsaussichten und wie bewerten Sie
das sehen wir da gerade Proteste die
sich wirklich nur gegen diese 0
kovid-politik richten oder geht es da
auch in Richtung Systemwandel
also ich glaube zunächst mal muss man
feststellen dass es noch zu früh ist
jetzt endgültig zu sagen was genau der
Fokus der Proteste war wir hatten
sicherlich auf jeden Fall
unterschiedliche Gruppierungen Leute mit
unterschiedlichen Interessen ich glaube
aber was und der Kern sicherlich wie
auch schon erwähnt waren die oder die
Ursache waren die stricken
lockdown-maßnahmen aber ich glaube die
Leute haben erkannt dass das etwas
systemisches ist das ist nicht nur lokal
vor Ort an der Willkür der einzelnen
Kader liegt sondern das ist ein Teil des
ganzen Systems ist das
Verwaltungssystems was ja sehr stark
dann auch diesen politischen Druck von
oben wir brauchen auf jeden Fall eine 0
sozusagen vor der nach der Gleichung
nach unten weiter gibt und teilweise
natürlich auch die lokalen Kader vor Ort
alleine lässt dass es gewisse
Zielkonflikte gibt zwischen eben die
Produktion aufrecht zu erhalten aber
möglichst wenig oder keinen kuvit Fall
zu haben und natürlich auch das haben
die Leute sehr sowohl mitbekommen das
ist ja auch schon erwähnt worden wie
viel an Informationen manipuliert wird
wie viel verschwiegen wird wie auch
Informationen gegen Leute verwendet
werden also ich glaube es gibt schon
eine wachsende Zahl der Bevölkerung die
den Eindruck haben dass es etwas was
wirklich System hat und damit kommen wir
natürlich an die Frage des politischen
Systems ich denke aber nicht dass es
jetzt wirklich genuin und einen Umsturz
geht oder um allgemeine freie gleiche
Wahlen aber darum dass das bestehende
System sich verbessern muss
transparenter werden muss und eben
wirklich mehr auf die Belange der
Bevölkerung eingehen sollte auf sich der
Bevölkerung
ja das sind zum einen die Forderung der
Menschen die da protestieren was glauben
Sie was werden wir denn in den nächsten
Tagen und vielleicht Wochen erleben wie
wird Shisha in Ping denn ganz konkret
reagieren
das ist natürlich genau die spannende
Frage die wir uns jetzt alle Stellen ich
glaube man es gibt verschiedene Faktoren
zum einen wird eine große Rolle spielen
wie jetzt genau eine gelockerte
veränderte Form der 19 Politik
kommuniziert wird was natürlich jetzt
auch gerade in Anbetracht der steigenden
Zahlen nicht ganz einfach ist normales
glaube ich auch eine Gruppe in der
Bevölkerung gibt auch das ist vorhin
schon angesprochen worden die nach wie
vor sich sehr unsicher fühlen die
eigentlich dankbar sind für diese harten
Maßnahmen und eben große Sorger haben
also das ist die Frage wie kommuniziert
die chinesische Regierung solche
Veränderungen und reicht das dann um
solche Proteste sozusagen auch kurz bis
mittelfristig zu ersticken oder sehen
wir selbst wenn jetzt diese Prozesswelle
sozusagen abgeerbt ist aufgrund der
massiven Polizeipräsenz an den einigen
Tagen oder Wochen eine erneute Eruption
von Protesten weil Menschen immer noch
den Eindruck haben sozusagen sie haben
nicht Bezug Raum um das Leben zu
gestalten es wird nicht transparent und
klar kommuniziert also das ist die große
Frage natürlich auch wie sehr bringt das
jetzt die politische Führung
umschienenping sozusagen selbst in in
Widerspruch zueinander also eine
Spaltung ist zumindest nicht in Sicht
aber wir wissen ja auch dass die Politik
von cheating nicht ganz unumstritten war
es gab vor dem 20 Parteitag auch immer
mal wieder stimmen die gesagt haben wir
müssen eigentlich doch viel mehr wieder
die Wirtschaftsdynamik entfachen und
viel früher lockern also das wird
natürlich auch interessant sein
inwieweit ist da gelingt mögliche Risse
innerhalb der politischen Führung zu
verdecken und wirklich dann auch
geschlossen nach außen und gegenüber der
Bevölkerung aufzutreten
ja wir haben hier gerade Bilder gesehen
vom Parteitag im Oktober über den ja
auch viel berichtet wurde sie haben es
gerade schon angeschnitten unser YouTube
User so und nicht anders fragt inwiefern
können solche Proteste hier Gins
innerparteilichem Rückhalt schaden sie
haben gerade gesagt das sehen sie jetzt
erstmal nicht könnte aber vielleicht
nachgelagert oder in fernerer Zukunft
mal eine Möglichkeit sein
auf jeden Fall zu mal wie gesagt es
deutlich wurde von dem was wir als
BeobachterInnen und Beobachter sehen das
müssen wir auch ganz bescheiden sagen
das ist natürlich nur ein kleiner
Einblick in das was innerhalb der
politischen Elite diskutiert wird aber
wir haben gesehen auch durch den jetzt
noch amtierenden Ministerpräsident Lieke
Klagen der sich ja nachdrücklich immer
wieder für eine Vitalisierung der
Wirtschaft ausgesprochen hat auch
grundsätzlich natürlich mehr Markt und
mehr Freiraum für wirtschaftliche
Prozesse sich gewünscht hat das ist in
der Tat diese Kritik gab an der Null
Politik und damit natürlich in großer
Art und Weise auch die Frage gestellt
wird diese Machtfülle die sich hier den
Ping jetzt verschafft hat auch mit der
Skrupellosigkeit mit deren er sämtliche
Regeln die sich die kommunistpartei ja
selbst gegeben hat aus guten Grund weil
man eben eine ein Parteienherrschaft
nach den Erfahrungen der kulturvolution
verhindern wollte dass es sicherlich
auch etwas was da haben wir auch
einzelne Zeichen innerhalb der
politischen Eliten auch nicht auf nur
Begeisterung gestoßen ist also sie den
Ping ist natürlich damit auch unter
enormen Druck er allein ist jetzt
wirklich verantwortlich er kann keinem
anderen die Schuld zu schieben und das
bringt sicherlich durchaus einen
erhöhten Druck jetzt auf das politische
System bzw auch die politische Elite
ja so viel vielleicht einmal zur
Innensicht in den
Regierungsapparat wir wollen den Blick
noch mal so ein bisschen nach außen
richten und haben hier eine sehr
berechtigte Frage von einem YouTube User
der fragt wie sind die Informationen
über den Brand innerhalb Chinas
eigentlich bekannt geworden gerade vor
dem Hintergrund der staatlichen Zensur
und nachgelagert wie werden sich die
Proteste ihrer Meinung nach
weiterentwickeln
auch sehr wichtige Frage also alles
tolle Fragen großes Kompliment auch
anders Publikum wie sind die Bilder oder
die Informationen bekannt geworden das
ist trotz der
Zensur die natürlich zum einen auf KI
auf künstliche Intelligenz zurückgreift
und auch auf menschliche Zensoren die
dann wirklich systematisch soziale
Medien durchsuchen und Meldungen löschen
aber die schiere Masse jetzt auch im
Fall dieser Protest aber auch mit Blick
auf die Ereignisse oder muss sie machen
es nicht möglich das flächendecken zu
löschen das wird dann wieder weiter
gepostet in andere Gruppen hinein es gab
auch Plattformen wo ich persönlich den
Eindruck hatte die haben versucht das
gezielt auch möglichst lange stehen zu
lassen dieses Thema um einen gewissen
auch Raum zu bieten Informationen zu
teilen weil dort natürlich teilweise
auch Leute sitzen Journalisten
Journalistin die mitleiden und die eben
nicht möchten dass solche Informationen
unterdrückt werden also kurz und da
gibt's natürlich trotz alledem Mittel
und Wege
diese auch natürlich sehr kreativ mit
anderer Wortwahl teilweise dann solche
Zensur zu umgehen also das funktioniert
trotz aller Zensur und die Frage jetzt
wie die Proteste sich weiterentwickeln
werden
kurzfristig ist natürlich die große
Frage
reicht aus Sicht der chinesischen
Führung die massive Polizeipräsenz die
Verhaftungen möglicherweise der Netz
auch die die Kommunikation die einsetzt
dass das ausländische Kräfte mit
angezettelt haben vielleicht auch das
gesagt wird das sind Leute die die
soziale Ordnung stören das ist so ein
gängiges Muster wir müssen uns doch
jetzt auf die gemeinsame Bekämpfung von
Kurven konzentrieren und nicht wir
brauchen nicht solche Unruhe Stifte da
einen Anführungszeichen also ob das
erfolgreich ist aus sich der
chinesischen Regierung diese Proteste
Welle jetzt zu brechen das ist das eine
und das zweite natürlich wie gesagt ob
die Anpassung in der Politik dann
reichen um auch kurz bis mittelfristig
jetzt eine erneute Protestwelle dann zu
verhindern
ja wir werden sehen wie sich das
entwickelt vielleicht so ein bisschen
abschließend auch noch mal eine wichtige
Frage wir haben jetzt hier einen
innenpolitischen Konflikt in China
inwiefern kann denn so ein
innenpolitischer Konflikt die Gefahr
erhöhen das heaging den Konflikt und
Taiwan anheizt um vielleicht von diesen
Problemen im Land abzulenken
auch das ist natürlich ein sehr
gewichtige Frage sehr wichtige Frage ich
denke jetzt ganz akut eher nicht weil
ich glaube jetzt die chinesische
Regierung damit beschäftigt ist in der
Tat ja jetzt auch noch diese
Prozesswelle einzuordnen auch zu
bewerten bislang fehlt das ja noch das
ist oft so dass man sich auch erst
intern wie gesagt abstimmen muss was
bedeutet das jetzt genau wie
kommunizieren wir darüber aber dann
sicherlich jetzt ganz akut erstmal damit
beschäftigt ist die die Kurve bzw auch
die Wirtschaftspolitik noch mal neu zu
justieren jetzt im nächsten Jahr im März
steht ja der Nationale Volkskongress vor
der Tür dort wird die Staatsführung
ausgetauscht teilweise wir hatten jetzt
im Oktober die alte neue Parteiführung
um die bestätigt worden ist also ich
glaube jetzt wirklich ganz kurzfristig
in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten
rechne ich nicht damit aber darüber
hinaus gerade wenn auch die
wirtschaftliche Situation und das Ringen
darum auch innerhalb der politischen
Eliten und der Gesellschaft vorhanden
bleibt dann ist das leider durchaus eine
reale Möglichkeit die wir gut beobachten
müssen
ja wir werden das auf jeden Fall weiter
beobachten vielen Dank für dieses
Gespräch Frau schekupfer vielen Dank
sehr gerne danke Ihnen für die guten
Fragen und danke an das Publikum
ja ihr habt auf jeden Fall ziemlich
heftig diskutiert ich gucke hier zum
Schluss noch mal in Eure Kommentare und
sehe dass die Meinung ziemlich
auseinander gehen hier ist zum Beispiel
der YouTube User TKS Foto der sagt ich
kann mir vorstellen dass es bald zu
Unruhen kommen kann und dann lese ich
aber auch andere Kommentare wie vom
YouTube User die Mode 13 niemals ist das
eine Gefahr für sie diejenigen die
protestieren werden bestimmt verhaftet
und nie wieder gesehen und vielleicht
kann man abschließend aber noch sagen
das ist der Facebook kommentar von Jan
door mutige Menschen die in einem Land
wie China aufstehen und gegen die
autoritäre Führung protestieren ja wie
sieht diese Proteste weiterentwickeln
vielleicht in den nächsten Tagen in den
nächsten Wochen werden wir für euch hier
weiter verfolgen vielen Dank dass Sie
mit uns diskutiert habt vielen Dank für
eure Fragen wir sehen uns morgen hier
wieder um 19:30 Uhr bei ZDF heute live
wenn ihr mögt mir hat es großen Spaß
gemacht macht's gut